okay let's get into it but the official
line right now on Hillary Clinton's I
guess we'll call it a collapse or
fainting spell over the weekend is that
she indeed has pneumonia which she was
powering through to continue her
campaign a Friday morning she was
initially diagnosed with pneumonia she
was given antibiotics and it was
recommended to her by her doctor that
she cut back on the campaign schedule
she reportedly refused ended up keeping
a very full schedule over the weekend
and collapsed at a 911 event in New York
City on Sunday it was caught on video
and it propelled the Hillary health
story which had been sort of relegated
to the catacombs of the conspiracy
theory internet sites and and shows on
to corporate media and really really
into the mainstream let's go with this
story okay and i know many in our
audience have doubts about the
explanation I know that I've expressed
that at minimum it was a story that was
really not well handled by Hillary's
team let's go with the story that
Hillary Clinton was indeed diagnosed
with pneumonia on Friday like many
people she continued to work through an
illness that as as people do whether or
not they're running for president and
that things came to a head at the 911
event on Sunday okay can we say that
this was objectively a mistake by the
Clinton campaign defenders of Hillary
Clinton's campaign have written to me
and they said David she didn't announce
her illness because she's stronger than
that and she wasn't looking for sympathy
and she was continuing to campaign
that's why there was no announcement of
the illness on Friday she didn't want to
take time off because that would have
drawn attention and she quite frankly
didn't think that she needed to take
time off there are others who have
written to me and they've said well
David think about it uh Hillary Clinton
is already being slammed in the
catacombs of the Internet as I said for
supposedly hiding a serious illness so
it would be obvious that even if it's
something like treatable pneumonia that
is not completely incapacitating her
that she wouldn't mention
so a lot of people emailing me and
saying it's perfectly reasonable that it
wasn't mentioned I absolutely agree with
that but Hillary Clinton need not
mention that she has pneumonia if it's
something that is up presumably not
going to affect her race for president
or her campaigning etcetera in the same
way that Trump doesn't have to report if
he has a cold or a tonsillectomy or
whatever right but there's no doubt that
now the story is not going away Donald
Trump has been pushing the Hillary
health stuff for a while he now has more
ammunition the right wing shows like
Alex Jones there apoplexy over this
they've been going crazy for months
without something like this happening it
now it happened and they're completely
off the wall emboldened corporate news
sites talked about it for 24 even 48 now
as we get to the 48-hour mark after this
story and more they keep talking about
it is there a silver lining here maybe
uh Hillary Clinton has agreed to release
additional medical information soon in
the coming days presumably this week if
she releases something which the vast
majority of people who are keyed into
this story see and if it has the effect
of saying you know what it's just
pneumonia it's being treated Hillary
Clinton is healthy hear her medical
reports records whatever that may
actually calm the situation down and
really remove a lot of the fodder from
the at least corporate media stories
about this the problem of course is you
know that Alex Jones is going to say
whatever she releases is either
fraudulent or incomplete or deceptive so
I don't know that we're going to reach
those people but the silver lining could
be the medical records come out because
people are paying more attention as a
result of the incident on 911 it has
more of a positive impact for her now
for everyone emailing me saying nobody
on Hilary staff did anything wrong
nobody on Hillary staff misstepped even
the Clinton camp disagrees with you
Clinton's own aides acknowledged
yesterday that they did take too long to
explain what was going on and uh if you
were you were defending an organization
that itself now admits did make some
missed
what is Donald Trump been doing well he
said that he had a physical last week
feels great and is going to be appearing
on the dr. Oz Show to talk more about
the results of that physical sounds
about right the reality show candidate
is going to release his physical report
or medical records or whatever you want
to call it on the TV show of a doctor
who put pushes all sorts of non-science
supplements that actually does sound
exactly spot on to me big picture this
is not going away there are seven weeks
left until the election in early
November uh the only question I have is
not whether this is going to be pushed
under the rug for the next seven weeks
it will not be the question I have is
will Donald Trump bring up anything
related to Hillary's health at the
debates I don't know that I have an
answer yet I think the answer depends on
number one what is ultimately in the
records that Trump releases and number
two what is ultimately in the records
that Hillary Clinton says she is going
to release but send me your thoughts is
there any way Trump could include a
discussion or mention of this in the
debates in a way that would help him
rather than just make him look like a
guy who's talking out of school